all right things learned while watching
underworld kate beckinsale looks really
good in black leather Underworld
Awakening now i've never seen any of the
underworld films so I'm kind of a noob
to this franchise so I was thinking I'm
not really gonna understand this am I so
I started looking it up and I realized
that it's kind of a standalone film
basically the first 10 minutes of the
film sums up all the previous sequels
and so you can actually just walk right
into this movies if you've never seen in
the others which was very good for me
it's got Kate Beckinsale in it and we
know this story it's vamps versus like
and it's just a giant war and it seems
like a really cool idea you know you
could really wring a lot of really fun
sci-fi action good visuals just a good
fun time right lots of fighting moves
and all kinds of stuff couldn't you I
was held captive for 12 years
subject to escape but somewhere in the
building so this one opens up and
apparently now the humans are aware of
these creatures in this whole war and
kate beckinsale gets like captured and
frozen in this this chamber and wakes up
like 12 years later in a completely
different world and now she has to
figure out what's going on there's this
hybrid child that's apparently hers and
she has to protect it now from
werewolves and all kinds of things there
was this giant thing after her and she
doesn't understand why and to be honest
and they do we
this is a new war I was willing to give
this movie a chance in fact that was
actually kind of looking forward to
seeing it I was hoping to see some cool
sci-fi action I was hoping to just just
to have a fun kind of throw away
dispensable guilty pleasure like time
with the movies did I have that no this
movie opens BAM with a really cool shot
doesn't even fade in just BAM it hits
you and I thought that's a really cool
shot then it went away in about a split
second replaced with another shot split
second later another shot that I know I
shot then another shot poor editing
continued the film went on and on it was
just a whole bunch of a special-effects
action that looked unrealistic
you know characters are flipping and
turning and flying and jumping and
landing and none of it looks realistic
none of it looks like snot work it's
just CGI enhanced bodies doing things
like it Matrix Reloaded all the Smiths
flying everywhere II just you don't buy
it I used to hear stories of exactly
visit but they were a thing of the past
yeah but your channel don't recognize
this way to be honest this is like a
Paul WS Anderson film I mean if you just
swapped Emilio vabase with Kate
Beckinsale you would have a Paul WS
Anderson film and he is one of my least
favorite directors out there apparently
someone told the filmmaker said if every
single light in this film consistently
flashes on and off over and over again
for no reason that it will improve the
movie and make it more entertaining
somehow but no it's just an annoyance if
you have epilepsy do not see this movie
you will have a seizure and die in your
seat in the movie theater it seemed like
every room they went into that
electricity the light just kept
malfunctioning and flashing like make it
some music video it's like the
filmmakers thought that it would just
somehow distract people from the fact
that nothing really interesting is
happening because the story is not
interesting in this movie
if you're fans of the others I'm the I
can't really recommend it to you because
it's it sucks matches it's so bad when
the redeeming qualities this movie is
there isn't really any shaking camp even
though the action is silly and
over-the-top and video game sq can still
at least tell what's going on also Kate
Beckinsale is not a bad actress but
there is no good performances in this
movie because it's just a whole bunch of
just stale line readings basically to
continue the story on that doesn't
really have any depth or emotional
weight I'm gonna give Underworld
Awakening a d-minus I'd like to know
what's your favorite underworld movie
and do you think I should watch the
first one because I just leaving this
theater I wasn't terribly excited about
seeing anymore
if you liked this review you can
subscribe my channel and get stunning
eyes